last week you probably noticed a decline
in quality and Fox News programming I
was on vacation I apologize for that I
regret my leaving as much as you regret
me being gone after all you had to put
up with this guy thank you all for
having me great I'm not explaining you I
am NOT as funny as Greg Gutfeld Oh
morning everybody at home you don't have
to warn us I love you Shawn and for what
though research shows vacation benefits
vanish in just days here's why for dopes
like me we don't do jobs that actually
need rest
I don't risk my life pulling kids from
flooded caves I don't lift heavy objects
unless it's this which is out almost in
a month the only risk I incur is when
Kimberly notices a shoe missing my
vacations are like surgery you should
only have them if you need them because
if you don't vacation stress just adds
to the anxiety of work vacations for me
are like hair dye for brian Stelter and
it's not work you need rest from its the
modern technology that follows us
everywhere every person on the beach was
on the phone all talking at once while
their kids peed in the sand
what's with people kids peeing in the
sand it's not adorable but also going on
vacation while Donald Trump is in office
that's like closing your eyes during the
scary parts of a movie or going for a
hot dog in the ninth inning you know
you're gonna miss something because
after all the media says the world's
gonna end at any minute so maybe it's
good to be at the beach here are some
pictures this is the ocean and some
mountains yep
mountains and here's a rooster I don't
see you in any of them I know amazing
right
I could have saved money staying home
and googling oceans mountains and
roosters glad I said roosters I could
have saved you the pain of my absence
and once again I would have beaten
Jessie on a Saturday night but I didn't
because I wasn't here instead I flew
forever for a sunburn they
needed a case of Advil the upside on
vacation oh god this one member on
vacation nobody bugs you for guzzling
rum before 9 a.m. but after 10 days of
that it knocks off 20 IQ points meaning
I can now guest host Morning Joe best
part yes
that picture was like wow what was it
something you just say it woke you up
yeah totally scared me when I saw screen
was on really right and then your face
was there it was like miss me I miss
myself my wife created what's called a
texting burka because you can't see your
phone do you have it you can't see your
phone on the beach so this is this is
Elena all week sitting there texting
with her shirt over it I don't know if
that says something about her or you yes
don't you find more stress because so
I'm Peter and I have our 20th wedding
anniversary in the end of September
happy and we're meant to go on a
week-long trip to Europe right
but I'm very stressed because nobody has
planned it yet it's right when the
Supreme Court vote could be happening
and I'm feeling already like oh maybe we
shouldn't go but of course you go on the
vacations to mark special occasions so
I'm yes I know II mean yeah Jesse I was
not I was not sober by noon because they
allow you to drink at the beach like at
9:00 a.m. are you sober now I am I'm
punch-drunk
I have to call you out in a few things
John you were texting and tweeting and
instagramming a lot during your vacation
I noticed it
don't act like you unplug Greg oh I
didn't know I did not unplug I am
pathetic very capable of unplugging and
also I just want to go on record I'm
jealous that you got Hannity to say I
feel like I should have maybe gotten
someone like Hannity to fill in for me
I'll take that up with the producers in
a second I think Sean saw he's being
nice to you for your birthday
[Laughter]
and are you denigrating to people that
sub for you
who's some screwy I never watch everyone
does a great job one clean-up on Aisle
seven
why you don't eat you're not even
engaged in social media when you're here
that's true so but but I have to unplug
because like Dana said or I think you
said - it's the deluge with trunk yeah
it never stops and here's the other part
of it I I really I'll call you on it
just like Jesse I don't get it how you
can say you don't need a vacation
because you're not working and like in a
factory or something I find this at
times to be very stressed of course I'm
the I'm the lone liberal the table if I
get beat up but but I must say I think
there's a lot of stress to just trying
to think through figure things out
understand what really is going on
talking to people so that we're prepared
for the show but I will say like that
last week you had a whole week off I
only had like I think I had three days
after fourth of July and coming back
they asked me to come back a little
early because of the Supreme Court pick
I was like getting depressed oh my god I
got to get back put the harness on I
came back from a few days vacation I'm
in Beach mode and I'm just owning out
like this and Richard Fowler sitting in
your seat again no Greg it was for the
like food eating contest and I had like
really like no chicken wings bob was not
the soft time Yeah right kind so not
that easy Jesse totally choked on a
McNugget within how many how was Tyrus
he was mentary to you that it will be
better I'll kick his ass okay I'm joking
he could just crush me like a bug like a
bug